we should be honest about that when we
talk about justice when we talk about
compromise when you talk about cancel
culture okay because we are not on an
even playing field here I'll give you an
example
Ilhan Omar an elected US Representative
has said she wants to dismantle the
system I don't know why we still allow
her in Congress I don't know why we
still allow her in the United States
it's an outrageous statement to make and
we should kick her out if you don't like
this country and you want to completely
overturn it then go get out we don't
want you here go away we want you if you
like America you want to help build
America up if you want to tear America
down go away bye-bye see ya
but her comment was not even the
craziest comment made yesterday on the
internet that comment I guess it was
made a couple days ago comes from the
football player DeSean Jackson who
quoted Hitler he didn't really quote
Hitler because it was a fake Hitler
quote which is even worse I think that a
real Hitler quote cuz it's it's like a
dishonest Hitler quit what he's what he
said Hitler said is because the white
Jews knows that the Negroes are the real
children of Israel and to keep America's
secret the Jews will blackmail America
now the this idea that this fake Hitler
quote is espousing but DeSean Jackson's
especi is one that has become popular in
certain black nationalist circles which
is this idea that black people are the
real Jews and the Jews are the fake Jews
and it's a sort of odd theory F I've
spoken to people who preach about this
sort of thing on the street and it's
always an entertaining time but not very
convincing an incendiary quote for a
public figure to make finally he got
enough a little bit of pressure that he
apologized even his apology kind of weak
sauce
you know first off extend apology on the
behalf of me and what I stand for
because you know I'm when is fair and I
never want to put any rays down or any
people down
you know my post was definitely not
intended for any anybody of any race to
fill any self away especially the Jewish
community when I posted what I posted I
definitely didn't mean it to the extent
that you guys ticket and I just want to
let you guys know that I'm you know very
apologetic and I just want you guys to
understand that it never was intended to
be you know to put any race down or any
religion down you know I post things on
my story all the time and you know I
just thought he should have never posted
anything here there because Hitler was a
bad person I know that and you know I
was just trying to open if you know
african-americans and slavery and you
know just enlighten my people so he did
say one true thing in the apology which
is that Hitler was a bad person that's
so so big of you to concede that deshaun
that Hitler was a bad person but of
course nothing else he said makes any
sense what do you do you mean you posted
a quote that you thought was from Hitler
talking about how the evil white Jews
are blackmailing America and they're not
even the real Jews but you didn't mean
that to be offensive toward any group of
people or put down any race of people
right I mean it was that that's hard to
believe that and then even when he says
I didn't mean it in the way that you're
taking it well Atwood it's like our
fault it's people's the people's fault
that we objected to this guy posting a
Hitler quote and then he posts this
video apology which doesn't make any
sense and he'll get away with it it
won't matter at all he will face
absolutely no consequences do you
remember when the Oklahoma State
football coach just a few weeks ago had
the audacity to be seen in a photograph
wearing an oem shirt a shirt of his
favorite cable news station and he
almost lost his job for that and the
Oklahoma State football team almost fell
apart because of that because that was
so outrageous and politically incorrect
to watch a cable news channel that's how
he was treated it was an it was an
international incident practically
and yet DeSean Jackson talking about how
much he admires Hitler with a fake
Hitler quote there there will be no
problem
he'll be fine he'll face no consequences
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description